what is so bad
is this crisis
is man-made
it is caused by deliberate political
decisions
by this administration by joe biden
and by cumberland
texas lawmakers are tearing into the
biden administration over the border
crisis as migrants continue to pour into
the u.s and the situation grows
increasingly dangerous for border patrol
agents joining me now to discuss retired
acting ice director and former border
patrol chief ron betello sir it is good
to see you this morning thank you for
being here we were just talking about in
the commercial break because i really
wanted to try and understand this a
little better uh the fact that you were
saying that at this point in the year we
should be seeing these numbers of
crossers trailing off until the end of
the year but you said that rulebook is
no longer here that is thrown out the
window can you explain
yes we are in
completely unprecedented territory you
know july went into the books at 212 000
plus
apprehensions encounters
at the southwest border july august
september traditionally had been lower
months of activity and so we're seeing
an unprecedented crush of humanity
coming to this border right now i
suspect that august is going to be in
similar territory it's going to be a
record uh july was a 21-year record
the department has never seen anything
as big as we're seeing right now and we
may be in record territory as it relates
to the the entire history of our u.s
mexico border it's really unbelievable
and it's not just migrants who are
coming across it's the drugs too take a
look at these numbers the weight of
fentanyl seized at the border and as you
can see here this is in pounds i mean
look at this this is up nearly double
from just a year ago and nearly triple
from two years ago you're talking more
than 8 500 pounds of fentanyl seized at
the border and this is not just a border
problem then this is a problem for every
community in the united states correct
correct because that those drugs don't
stay at the border in places like rgb or
in laredo or del rio those are being
trafficked all over the united states
and
you know
those gangs uh those drugs are being
sold in communities across the united
states and so when you have i was at the
border a couple of weeks ago when you
have 40 percent of the workforce doing
something else besides patrolling the
border that means you're going to get
more chaos you're going to get more drug
smuggling you're going to get more human
trafficking children are going to be
exploited people in the pipeline are
in danger and again that stuff doesn't
stay at the border it goes throughout
the united states and so when you have
this kind of flow and a distracted
border patrol who are trained to patrol
the border not care and comfort for kids
and families
that's that's the result of what you're
going to have and then i'm grateful for
the cbp officers who stop that load of
fentanyl because that stuff is dangerous
in very very small quantities and so the
more of that that they can do the better
off we are but if as as this flow
is unending we're going to have more
challenges at the border we're going to
have more challenges like that
throughout the homeland well yeah and
they're trying to do their jobs the
border patrol agents and then they're up
against being assaulted themselves uh we
have a number of examples on wednesday
five people were arrested after an agent
was assaulted by a smuggler and then we
have another example that happened in
the overnight hours on saturday this was
around 3 15 in the morning let's go
ahead and pull up this quote here from
u.s customs and border protection and
this reads the agent was attempting to
apprehend approximately 12 to 15
migrants a smuggler in mexico struck out
at the agent through a slot in the wall
hitting the agent with a large object
believed to be a two by four board i
mean can you tell me what they're up
against as they're trying to do their
job on a daily basis
that that is the work that they do these
highly trained law enforcement officers
are prepared to face those kinds of
risks um but yeah you can see the the
ruthlessness of smugglers and people who
are trying to to evade arrest they're
willing to assault an agent to come into
the country and so they need to be
prepared we need to support them and we
need we need to make sure that they have
the tools that they have that they need
to do their jobs and in a case like this
you would hope that the u.s attorney's
office in san diego will prosecute that
smuggler for the assault on that agent
and so that's that's an important
aspect of this right we want to close
the loop and make sure people are held
to account for the lawlessness that that
could occur on the border absolutely and
real quick we have a picture that we can
pull up of that border patrol agent's
injuries and you know this is just one
example i'm sure many some that we don't
even hear of
right ron a few seconds left
yeah
one of the most assaulted workforces
in law enforcement in the united states
and so yeah that it's unfortunate that
that happened and and i hope that agent
recovers quickly uh and is back on the
job soon okay ron vitello retired acting
ice director thank you so much for
waking up early and joining us
appreciate your time
have a good time